what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
we just watched Loki season 2 episode 2
and everything seems to be in absolute
Peril right now the TVA is split in half
with some of the TVA members wanting to
give all of the timelines and all of the
people absolute free will but some of
them have went and pruned pretty much
all of the timelines with the exception
of a few if you paid attention you'll
notice that they said Sylvie was on a
branched timeline in the show they did
not say she was on the main timeline
like Hunter X5 or Brad wolf was and
Sylvie was able to go back to her
timeline after the TVA Rogue agents
deleted all of the other timelines so
her timeline her Branch timeline was
safe now the Rogue TVA agents pruned
most of the branch timelines but we know
that more are going to grow out so
moving forward the question is how do
you keep all of these timelines now safe
safe from one people trying to prune
them if you recall Hunter D90 at the end
of this episode said that they got all
of them except for the few who managed
to escape speaking of the TVA agents who
were working for General docs to prune
all of the branch timelines so there are
still Rogue TVA agents out there and two
of course King the Conqueror and all of
his many variants so not only do they
have to worry about that but they also
have to figure out a way to increase the
time looms capacity to handle all of
those branch timelines Obi says that he
can fix it but they need the temporal
aura of he who remains or they need Miss
minuts to come back in order to give
them access to actually go out and fix
it and this is probably where Victor
timley comes into play Mobius and Loki
are going to go out in search somewhere
of a Kang variant which is when Victor
timley will come into play and they will
most likely have to take him back to the
TVA and since we have seen him in some
of the trailers looking at what seems to
be a scale model of the time Loom it
does appear that at some point in time
in a future episode they are going to
get Victor time back to the TVA which
makes you wonder if he's good or if he's
bad because we know that out of all of
the king variants out there not all of
them are going to be truly bad there are
going to be some good variants of King
the Conqueror out there in the comics
there is the classic iron lad variant
iron lad is a variant of King the
Conqueror he is Nathaniel Richards but
he is good I'm really hoping we run into
him at some point in time in Loki if not
in Loki sometime in secret Wars or maybe
Deadpool 3 because we do know that there
are going to be good King variants it's
only a matter of time until we meet them
Victor timely might be good but at the
same time this could be all a part of
his plan we'll have to wait and see but
let's dive in to our breakdown for Loki
season 2 episode 2 and of course be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to stay up to date with all things
Loki season 2 and the MCU and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items and some
DC items as well the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month so this episode starts
off with Mobius and Loki going to the
Past in 1977 in London in the UK and
Loki immediately says sylv's not here
the second that Mobius gets out of the
time door he says thoughts Loki takes a
quick look around and says she's not
here and Loki just knows she's not there
Mobius asks why and he says it's too
safe it's not an apocalypse it's not a
war zone and this goes back to last
season where Loki realized that Sylvie
was hiding on Branch timelines that were
about to have catastrophic apocalyptic
events because nothing will set off the
radar because it doesn't matter because
that timeline is about to die or if
they're on the main timeline the place
that she's at is about to essentially be
extinct as well so Sylva usually hides
at events and time that are about to be
catastrophic events where everybody who
is involved with those events dies so
right away Loki says sylv's not here no
way it's too safe knowing this is a
place that Sylvie would never go to and
if she did she would not stay there
however they got a hit on a temp pad
that belonged to Hunter X5 so they are
going to explore London in 1977 in
search for X5 to see if he found Sylvie
and they start walking and if you notice
on the right side you can see a poster
of Kingo from the eternals as we know
over the years Kingo became a famous
actor for many generations just simply
claiming that he was the son or grandson
or great-grandson of essentially himself
so that poster is for a movie of which
he is going to star in now Mobius and
Loki say that the temp pad for Hunter X5
went dark which means Sylvie could have
found him first which is why it went
dark basically stating if she did find
him or he found her she probably killed
him so they go inside this theater and
we can see by the display on the outside
that Hunter X5 is now an actor called
Brad wolf basically he pulled a Kingo
used his knowledge and advanced
technology to get gain in the world and
it works cuz now he is super famous now
at first Loki and Mobi don't know if
this is simply an act and he's still
trying to complete his mission to find
Sylvie Loki says X5 is an actor now and
mobus says or maybe he's undercover Loki
says this looks pretty real to me and of
course they find out that he has a whole
life here now and he is not undercover
now when Brad wolf is talking to some of
the press there we can see some posters
in the background for zaniac and his
character kind of looks like the Hulk
he's big and he's green so I'm sure he
kind of modeled his character off of the
Hulk since he most definitely knows who
the Hulk is with his time working in the
TVA another member of the press asks
about the Bridget BAU rumors and Bridget
BAU was a famous French actress during
that time and a little bit before she
actually did Don Juan in 1973 which you
probably at some point in time have seen
her in if not the movie then a poster or
a picture online somewhere so it's
always fun to see the MCU tie-in real
life things into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now ultimately Mobius and Loki
of course find him he tries to sneakily
get away at first it doesn't work then
he says all right I actually have some
stuff to tell you got to catch you all
up acting like he's still on his mission
and he says but let's get a drink first
Mobius agrees Loki obviously knows that
he doesn't want to get a drink but
Mobius is kind of trying to have a good
time while they're on Earth he likes a
lot about Earth we know that from Loki
season 1 so he says it's okay to have a
drink here but then of course Loki goes
is he running and Mobius goes he is now
this is an important scene that you have
to look closely at he tries to run out
the back door and then Hunter B15 kind
of tricks him here she says oh my gosh
it's Brad wolf can I have your autograph
he stops because of course he loves
being famous and he says anything for a
fan but when he turns around it's hun
B15 and you have to look closely but
notice that she takes his tin pad she
seems to have it all and is about to
take it from him but then he takes a
part of it off of it and runs away but
hunter B15 is left with his actual temp
bat in her hands which is how she gets
it later he runs but ultimately Mobius
grabs him and Brad says come on Mobius
you're going to ruin my life here
meaning that this is him now he is gone
Rogue from the TVA no longer wants to be
a TVA agent but wants to be Brad wolf
this is his life and we actually don't
have have any idea how long he's been
living there because of course time
works so differently he could have
gotten there at 1967 and could have been
living on the sacred timeline for 10
years but Mobius and Loki showed up at
1977 so it was only a quick few moments
for them but as usual Mobius wants some
answers and Loki does things his own way
and he hits him with the blast of his
energy sending him flying down the
stairs and let's take a moment to admire
the Swagger of Tom heston's Loki as he
walks down this alley and he unbuttons
his coat big Loki Vibes here Brad of
course continues to run away but Loki
catches him but here we see that Brad
still has some pieces of TVA technology
on him including the watch that you can
see here and a piece that he ripped off
the temptin pad so he doesn't travel
through time but he can travel through
space teleporting himself but
unfortunately he is running from the god
of mischief and when he tries to run
away he finds himself surrounded by many
many people who seemingly want to jump
him but when he grabs a metal pipe and
seemingly goes to attack he realizes
they are all an illusion created by Loki
he says to fight fair and Loki States
the obvious it's not a fair fight he is
fighting with a literal God we've seen
Loki cast Illusions before obviously
this was a really big thing from doing
it with his brother Thor we've seen him
trick Thor too many times with that and
even in Loki season one we've seen the
other variants of Loki like the classic
original comic book version of Loki that
we saw cast an insane illusion of the
entirity of Asgard so this is no
surprise from us but when Loki
eventually does catch Brad we see
something new here we see Loki's Shadows
start to go onto the wall and they
physically grab him and detain him mobus
says don't you think that was a little
over the top and he's talking to the
center Loki because there are three of
them so he's talking to the one in the
middle however the one on the right side
turns and looks to him and says I think
it was spot on what this does is show us
just how real Loki's Illusions are and
he can use any one of them to speak so
they go back to the TVA and they put him
in a holding cell and here they reveal a
little bit about X5 stating that he
never really goes quite quietly but
he'll talk once he's had some time in
the holding cell meanwhile a hunter B15
has his temp pad that has been modified
so she gives it to Mobius to take to OB
OB tells him that right now he's trying
to retrofit a device on the time Loom
that allows it to take in more timelines
that way it won't explode and kill
everybody so he asks if the tin pad is a
bigger priority than basically
everything exploding and them all dying
and of course they say no continue with
your work but we're reminded that Obi
wrote the entire TVA manual so he gives
it to them and says basically everything
that you need to know about a temp pad
is in this book meanwhile we see Casey
with Hunter B15 and she's wondering if
she has tracked Ren Slayer yet and he
says no and if you notice behind Hunter
B15 you can see the sacred timeline and
just how many Branch timelines there are
now the branch timelines are essentially
going off the screen now so there could
be millions of them because we know that
branches can grow off of other Branch
timelines and so on and so forth so
right now at this point in time there
could be literally thousands to hundred
hundreds of thousands to millions of
different Kang variants being created
from those branch timelines meanwhile
Loki and Mobius are trying to work with
the temp pad that they've got
unsuccessfully mobus says he can't focus
but Loki says here's what might help you
focus if we don't figure this out this
whole place is going to be destroyed
temporal meltdown or not and what he's
referring to is that yes they could die
to a temporal meltdown but even if that
doesn't happen he who remains and his
variants could come and destroy the
entire place if they don't figure it all
out soon Casey explains that Rin Slayer
and Miss minutes are now working
together and Loki starts to kind of
piece it all together Loki knows that
Miss minutes was there at the end of
time with he who remains and we know
that RN Slayer and he who remains worked
together before in the past because of
the audio recording that Loki heard so
Miss Mes and Rin Slayer working together
Mak sense because they're both going to
want to work for slash with he who
remains SL Kang SL any other variant
there might be that also explains to
them why there are no r radio coms that
are currently working and Casey explains
they have to do everything manually
because Miss minutes is gone Casey has
basically memorized the entire TVA
handbook so he looks at the tin pad and
says yeah X5 said this blocks TVA
tracking but that is not what it does so
they know he's lying so now it's time
for Hunter B15 Mobius and Loki the three
of them together to investigate so they
go to question Brad but Mobius offers a
warning first he says Brad knows us and
he knows our tactics but most of all
he's a jerk so don't let him get under
your skin now what's interesting is that
Brad actually outranked Hunter B15 and
he was in a very different department
than Mobius was in so he states that
nobody in that room has the rank or the
authority to detain him and Loki doesn't
even work there so he has no right to
detain him or question him at all and
here is where Brad starts to get under
the skin of Loki and Mobius and it's
actually quite an important scene for
Loki's character development Brad starts
to talk to Loki and he says we know what
you're trying to do you're trying to
make up for all the terrible things that
that you've done and we can see Loki
take a really big deep breath here and
we find out that Loki is not kidding
this isn't an act that he's putting on
to make it seem like Brad is getting
under his skin he is actually getting
under the skin of Loki and that is
because now Loki is trying to be a good
person he's actually trying to be the
hero of the entire Multiverse however
there are still those dark villainous
Roots inside of him so he tries to use
those to his Advantage Brad says he
always loses and I think we're seeing a
Loki who is not going to lose because
now he's on a different side he's not
bad he's good but he still can use those
bad sides of him and he approaches Brad
saying that yeah maybe I've just been
waiting for this moment right here to do
terrible awful things to you and in this
scene you can see Hunter B15 is pretty
uncomfortable Mobius too and you know
that they would both stop Loki if he
went to do anything to Hunter X5 that's
important for a later scene but Loki's
tactics of threatening Brad actually
don't work because Hunter be 15 and
Mobius are there fume is a GameChanger
for a lot of people in turning bad
habits into good habits a lot of people
struggle with these bad habits but fume
looks at these in a different way not
everything in the habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit and that's exactly what fume
does they're Innovative and they're
award-winning and they're a flavored air
device that's all it is it's flavored
air so it has none of the bad things and
the bad habit in it instead of vapor it
uses flavored Air instead of electronics
fume is completely natural and instead
of harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trf nume.com and use code Cosmic
to save 10% off when you get the journey
pack today that's
trf m.com and use code cos to save an
additional 10% off your order today he
knows Loki's not going to touch him
because they're going to interfere so he
basically says man Loki you need help
you're obsessed with Sylvie which is
basically being obsessed with yourself
you need therapy I can recommend
somebody getting under a skin once again
and from here Mobius tries to negotiate
with Brad he says look tell us where
Sylvia is tell us what you know and
we'll let you go back to the sacred
timeline and resume the life that you
made for yourself there you can go back
and be the famous Brad wolf I promise
but here is where Brad gets gets under
Mobius his skin he basically calls
Mobius a fool because they all now know
that the TVA isn't real the timekeepers
weren't real they didn't create them but
they did have something real before real
lives on the timeline and he calls
Mobius a fool because he hasn't
investigated what his old life was at
all and he tells him that until you
figure that out and start investigating
and find out what you were you're
nothing here and that really pisses off
Mobius to the point to where he punches
him so we see Mobius loses for the very
first time a side of them that I
actually really like and we find out why
very soon after Mobius and Loki go to
eat some pie and Mobius explains look
wasn't tactical I lost it and here looki
says something very funny and really
interesting he says do you remember that
one time where I was so angry with my
father and my brother and went down to
earth and I held New York City hostage
with an alien Army I went to use the
mindstone on Tony Stark it didn't work
so I threw him off the building it
wasn't tactical I lost it what's really
interesting is in this scene he's saying
do you remember that time like it was
very very long ago and it probably was
remember time passes differently in the
TVA and we know that Loki and Mobius
have gone to different parts in real
time and we don't know how long they've
been down there for so it could have
been months or years since that event of
Avengers in New York where Loki was the
villain with thanos's army because
judging by the way he talks about that
event like it was so long ago in the
past it does make it seem like a lot of
time has passed which also shows us that
the Loki we are seeing here has grown a
lot and has matured a lot up to the
point to where he's now trying to save
the entire Multiverse not rule over it
or destroy it but then Mobius explains
why X5 got under his skin Mobius knows
one life the life of being an analyst at
the TVA and he doesn't care if his life
on Earth would be worse than it was if
he were working at the TVA but he does
care if it would be better because then
he would have to live knowing what a
great life he had but no longer has the
TVA would be a great spot for him to be
in if his life on Earth was terrible but
if he found out his life on Earth was
awesome like he was writing a jet ski
every day of his life or selling them
which I believe he was on Earth we'll
find that out hopefully in a later
episode well then the life that he has
in the TVA would suck all of a sudden so
he doesn't want to know he doesn't want
to know about his old life in case it
was something fantastic and then he
would have to live with the fact that
that is no longer his life and he
himself didn't actually get to
experience it because he doesn't
remember it at all so ultimately while
they're having pie they realize what
Brad wants he wants to go back to the
timeline and be Brad Wolf the famous
movie star but they also realized that
he was insanely good at his job and he
probably did find Sylvie and he most
likely found Sylvie without her knowing
because if she knew she would have
killed him so they go back in and they
try a different tactic a very clever one
Loki comes back in and makes the joke
stating that he needs another session
referring to a therapy session because
Brad said he needed therapy stating that
he needs to get some stuff off his chest
and Brad is kind of chilling he doesn't
think that there's anything Loki or
Mobius or Hunter B15 can do to get him
to talk however he notices that a
machine is being brought into the room
and him being a TVA agent immediately
knows what this device is he immediately
knows that this is a device that could
seriously torture me or kill me so he
gets scared and he immediately asks
where Hunter B15 is because he knew that
she would keep Loki from doing anything
and Brad kind of realizes that that's
part of their tactic he goes okay so you
left her out on purpose to make me think
that you're going to hurt me the two of
them start talking and he says all right
who came up with this script which is
ironic because the whole thing was
scripted Loki says we don't have the
remote Mobius goes to step out and he
shuts the door behind Mobius now this
automatically catches the attention of
Brad but it is as we would go to find
out part of Mobius is in Loki's plan it
is a scare tactic and it definitely
works on B15 Loki shuts the door behind
Mobius and locks it Mobius Taps on the
glass saying hey don't do this this
what's going on let me in and Mobius
does this the entire time to add to
effect he keeps saying things like Loki
this isn't right and again this is to
freak Brad out and Brad is kind of
remaining cool he says yeah but it
doesn't work without the controller and
Loki of course had the controler the
entire time and when Brad sees it you
can actually see him turn back to look
at Mobius because now he's getting very
scared he even stands up and he keeps
trying to play it cool and he says you
almost got me but you don't know how to
work that however says you're right
though I a villain and he starts the
machine instantly in which Brad
immediately starts to step back and
immediately starts to apologize for what
he said to Loki before especially what
he said about his mother and now you can
see that Brad is scared he's alone there
with Loki the god of Mischief a villain
who he just insulted and told him he
should be a villain and that person just
looked him in the eye and said yeah
you're right I am a villain and this is
where Loki starts to mess with him he
says wow there must be a learning curve
to this thing Brad says says there is
you could kill me with that Loki looks
at him and says oh could I and traps him
in the box now Loki continues to shrink
the Box smaller and smaller and X5
continues to lie and Loki even makes fun
of him poking at Brad wolf he says I
want to believe you but you're such a
good actor obviously referring to Brad
wolf and the life that he's made on
Earth on the sacred timeline as an actor
ultimately Loki shrinks the Box until
it's about to crush Brad and kill him
inside and he says all right Sylvie got
a new life and Loki releases him this is
where he reveals that he did bail on his
mission he went to get an actual life on
the timeline but he did find Sylvie
first and he found out that she is on a
branch as in a branched timeline Mobius
then walks through the supposed locked
door and then Brad of course realizes
that it was all a performance they
planned the entire thing and he says all
right if I tell you will you let me go
back but Mobi says nope you're going to
show us so they go find Sylvie but
before they do that we cut to one of the
most important parts not only of this
episode but what I believe is going to
be one of the most important parts of
the series Casey and Hunter B15 go and
they find OB and OB states that they're
all going to die he states that the
blast doors are closed and unless they
can open them to go out and fix the loom
to make it able to handle more timelines
they're all going to die because it's
essentially going to explode and kill
them all and the problem is the only way
to open the door is to scan the temporal
Aura of the person who designed it AKA
he who remains AKA King the Conqueror so
he explains that there are only really
two ways to do this one is to get Mis
minutes to come back and over ride it
and open the blast doors or they get he
who remains or a variant with the same
temporal Aura to open it Obi says I can
build the device to fix it but you all
have to figure out how to open up the
blast doors get Miss minutes back or get
a variant of King and that is where I
believe Victor timley comes into play in
the next episode then Loki Mobius and
Dex 5 arrive in Brockton Oklahoma in
1982 where we saw Sylvie in the post
credit scene of episode 1 she is now
working at McDonald's and and once again
when they show us 1982 Brockton Oklahoma
they do specify that it is a branched
timeline now ever since the first moment
that they get there Brad is trying to
leave this Branch timeline em Mobius
even notices that something is up he
says why are you so jumpy but Brad makes
the excuse that he says he doesn't want
to see a variant that killed a bunch of
his own men but they all go inside Loki
walks up to Sylvie and she wants nothing
to do with him however he says they need
to talk and she says she takes a break
in 5 minutes and when they do start to
talk she really makes it known that she
doesn't want anything to do with him and
she is not happy that he's there but
Loki explains look the TVA is in big
trouble and I've been time slipping and
I went to the Future and I saw you so
it's going to happen the future is going
to happen you're going to go back to the
TVA for whatever reason I need to know
why but of course that's the future and
Sylvie hasn't lived through that part
yet so she says look I want to burn the
TVA to the ground trust me that would
make me happy but I'm good I don't want
to go back and I'm having a good life
here she is basically doing what she
always wanted to do and that's have a
very very ordinary normal life working a
normal job living a normal mundane life
to where people aren't constantly after
her trying to prune her and kill her and
here's where we really start to see The
Divide between Sylvie and Loki this is
the same divide that we saw in the
finale of Loki season 1 where Loki said
let's just take a minute to think about
what could happen if we kill he who
remains where Sylvia had already decided
she's going to kill him she's taken the
TVA down she doesn't care what happens
Loki says look if you don't work with me
I can't guarantee that this Branch
timeline is even going to be here
because if the TVA Falls and can't help
Kang could come and destroy it but
Sylvia doesn't care Loki even says
enchant me and Sylvia says no I'm not
going to because I don't care leave me
alone I gave everyone their freedom I
gave everyone free will and I'm done
that's it I don't care about the
consequences I'm done and we're starting
to see where Loki stands he says without
the TVA all of this everything the
Multiverse it's gone so Loki now
believes in what the TVA was doing at
least to an extent he maybe doesn't want
to Brun all of the timelines but he does
want to keep it in check but again
Sylvie wants nothing to do with it so he
says okay what if he who remains shows
up and Sylvie says I'll kill him and
then they're interrupted by Mobius who
needs to tell them what Brad told him is
about to happen so Brad starts saying if
we stay here we're going to die the
entire timeline's going to die and this
obviously gets Sylvia's attention
because she loves her life here so she
enchants him looks into his mind and
discovers that General Doc and her
followers are going to bomb every single
Branch timeline to make it to where
there is only the sacred timeline
remaining like the TVA is supposed to do
so Doc is clinging to the old ways of
the TVA and Sylvie takes Mobius and Loki
to where their headquarters has been set
up and here's where we find out why x5's
temp pad was modified they modified them
so that they could all be connected to
open up time doors to be able to prune
all of the branch timelines so Loki
Mobius and Sylvia attack and ultimately
Loki and Sylvia will join hands and use
their powers together to stop stop
everybody from pruning this is very
similar to what we saw with the final
episodes of Loki where the two of them
combined their powers to defeat aath now
ultimately they stop them but
unfortunately it's after they set off a
lot of reset charges we see Hunter D90
come in and mobia says this all of them
and he says it's all of General dox's
followers who didn't Escape so again
there are rogue agents out there they
head back to the TVA and Sylvie actually
follows and that's where they look at
the Monitor and they see that hundreds
and hundreds of brand timelines have
been destroyed and there are actually
only a handful of Branch timelines left
so General Doc and her followers have
killed essentially trillions of people
as this is happening Casey says that he
got a hit on Ren slayer's temp pad they
most likely discovered this because she
used her temp pad to leave a timeline
that was being deleted before she got
deleted herself so they're now able to
track Ren Slayer cut to Loki and sylv
and you can tell that both of them are
extremely upset about what has just
happened all of the innocent people
dying but again they have different
views on this Sylvie says this is the
tva's fault it's rotten it's broken but
Loki thinks that the TVA is actually the
only way to prevent this and he knows
that it's a harder way to do things but
it's probably the right way but
unfortunately Sylvie just leaves this
ultimately makes me believe that Loki
and Sylvie might have a fight like they
kind of had at the finale of season 1
Loki might try to essentially make the
TVA be responsible over the entire
Multiverse and might have a place in
that new TVA possibly as its ruler while
Sylvie doesn't want that sylv's whole
goal was Free Will and she's going to
fight to make everybody have free will
while Loki might believe that Free Will
essentially is going to cause the
destruction of the Multiverse so this
could be leading up to yet another
battle between Loki and Sylvie in the
finale Sylvie says that she's going back
to her timeline if it's even still there
since it was a branch timeline and we
see in the final scene that it is still
there and we also see that she still has
he who remains temp pad and we've yet to
see if that has any special properties
to it yet if it could do anything
anything very particular that a normal
tin pad could do I'd like to assume yes
because it was he who remains this tin
pad not just a normal TVA agent tin pad
you would assume it could do a lot more
but since she's playing with it at the
end of this episode or tinkering with it
we can assume that she's going to get
back in the game plus Loki did see the
future and she was there at the TVA so
if you think that sylv's tin pad now has
any different properties the normal ones
go ahead and let us know your theories
about that in the comments down below
and let us know what you thought about
Loki season 2 episode 2 don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest lowy
videos you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
woof